Scarlet Witch has a long history in the comics,
and with Wandavision, she's finally getting
her turn on the center stage of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe.
But even when she was more of a background
player, the MCU has been dropping Easter eggs
about her long history in Marvel comics.
It can sometimes take a while for Marvel Cinematic
Universe characters to take on the colorful
names of their comic book counterparts.
For example, Rhodey was only offhandedly referred
to as a "war machine" by Tony Stark in Iron
Man 2, and he didn't officially assume that
moniker until Iron Man 3.
Wanda Maximoff, on the other hand, has never
been called Scarlet Witch in any MCU film
— although she did finally acquire the name
in an episode of WandaVision.
"This is chaos magic, Wanda.
That makes you the Scarlet Witch."
Prior to that Disney+ program, the closest
audiences had gotten to seeing Wanda Maximoff
being called Scarlet Witch came during a small
piece of dialogue in Avengers: Age of Ultron.
In a scene when Tony Stark tries to calm Hulk
down after he's been enraged by Wanda Maximoff's
superpowers, Stark makes an early nod to Wanda's
comics name.
"That little witch is messing with your mind.
You're stronger than her.
You're smarter than her.
You're Bruce Banner."
Wanda never referred to herself as any kind
of witch during her subsequent film appearances,
but it seems likely that after WandaVision,
she'll own her superhero alter ego — Marvel
Studios chief Kevin Feige promised audiences
that WandaVision would see the character finally
become Scarlet Witch.
Wanda was introduced to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe before Disney purchased Fox, which
meant significant portions of her comics backstory
needed to be changed.
Because Wanda in the comics was both supposedly
a mutant and a mainstay on the Avengers team,
both companies had the rights to use the character
on screen.
However, both studios were restricted on what
they could do with Wanda — as well as her
brother Pietro Maximoff, a.k.a. Quicksilver.
For Marvel Studios, this shared custody agreement
meant that they could use Wanda, but couldn't
make her a mutant — or, obviously, the daughter
of Magneto.
Thus, while Wanda still has a twin brother
named Pietro Maximoff in the MCU, her parents
are normal human beings.
Another part of her origin story that was
altered: The MCU's version of Wanda hails
from the European country of Sokovia rather
than her original comic book country of origin,
Transia.
Though the names of the countries have changed,
Sokovia bears more than a passing resemblance
to Wanda's original homeland.
Like Transia, Sokovia is a fictional Eastern
European country rife with political turmoil
— making it a subtle nod to Wanda Maximoff's
original home for comics fans.
Not all superheroes start out as superheroes.
Some start out like Tony Stark — arrogant
people so blinded by their own wealth that
they can't see how their actions affect others.
Other superheroes begin their journeys as
outright supervillains — like Wanda Maximoff.
She and her brother Pietro began their time
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe as voluntary
human guinea pigs for the terrorist organization
known as Hydra.
These experiments gave them both their superpowers,
and they eventually joined forces with the
diabolical robot Ultron as his super-powered
henchmen.
In their time working for Ultron, Wanda and
her brother tormented the Avengers and helped
lay the groundwork for the maniacal robot's
plan for world domination.
While this is different from the duo's origin
story in the comics, it isn't a complete change
— Wanda also started out as a villain there
as well.
There, she and Pietro, as the children of
Magneto, were critical figures in the Brotherhood
of Mutants and frequently fought the X-Men.
Much like their film incarnations, though,
Wanda and Pietro didn't stay villainous for
long.
"How could you?
"
"How could I what?"
"You said we would destroy the Avengers make
a better world."
"It will be better."
In both mediums, they eventually turned against
their evil masters and went on to work for
the Avengers — just as comics readers always
suspected they would.
The suburban New Jersey setting of WandaVision
is a gift that keeps on giving.
On the surface, it allows the show to pay
homage to classic sitcoms, many of which also
take place in the suburbs.
It works for the show, but it wasn't just
invented for TV — this superhero duo's New
Jersey roots actually go all the way back
to an offbeat storyline in the 1985 comic
series The Vision and the Scarlet Witch.
In that series, the couple moves to the New
Jersey suburbs after getting married to enjoy
a life together.
Unfortunately, it isn't that easy — the
locals aren't happy with a human/android marriage
happening in their community.
That source of conflict in The Vision and
Scarlet Witch is more mundane than the supernatural
goings-on that fuel the plot of WandaVision,
but putting the pair in Westview adds connective
tissue to Wanda and Vision's prior comic book
series — as well as 2016's Vision series,
which saw the character of Vision once again
retreating to the suburbs with a new synthezoid
family.
In the MCU, Hawkeye and Wanda Maximoff have
developed a close bond since meeting in Avengers:
Age of Ultron.
Their first big meeting didn't seem to signal
that dynamic, though, as it entailed Wanda,
still working as a minion of Ultron, trying
to sneak up on Hawkeye only for the archer
to plug an electric arrow onto her forehead.
However, the two superheroes grew closer once
Wanda defected to the Avengers.
This was solidified by the climax of Age of
Ultron, which saw Hawkeye giving Wanda a big
speech about what it means to be an Avenger.
"The city is flying, we're fighting an army
of robots, and I have a bow and arrow.
None of this makes sense."
His rapport with Wanda took on a paternal
sense of protection after her brother Pietro
sacrificed himself to save Hawkeye.
Just like that, she had lost the only family
she had left in the world -- so Hawkeye stepped
in to help her feel like she still had somewhere
she belonged.
The pair has also had a close bond in the
comics, though it's been more complicated
there.
Instead of having paternal feelings for Wanda,
in the comics Hawkeye sees her more as a romantic
interest -- at least, until Vision shows up
in her life.
While their relationship has been altered
for the movies, Hawkeye and Wanda's closeness
in the MCU echoes the comics that came before
it.
Though WandaVision marks the first time Wanda
Maximoff has used her superpowers to create
a persistent alternate reality in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe, it's something she's accomplished
in the comics before -- more than once.
Her abilities in this department were most
famously the crux of the comic book storyline
House of M, which was penned by Brian Michael
Bendis in 2005.
Here Wanda, much like in WandaVision, is in
a period of deep emotional distress — though
in House of M her grief is the result of losing
her children, not losing Vision.
To cope with her crushing sadness, Wanda decides
to escape by creating her own alternate reality.
This decision doesn't just impact Wanda, though
— it sends the entire Marvel Universe into
chaos, creating a world run by mutants, under
the cold rule of the family of Magneto.
When the rest of the heroes in the Marvel
universe wake up to what's going on, they're
forced to come together to stop Wanda at any
cost and set the world right again.
Looking at House of M's broad strokes, it's
clear WandaVision takes cues from this comics
event, including the emphasis on Wanda navigating
very real emotional problems through her superpowers.
There are clear and major differences between
the comics and the show, but the similarities
between the two are impossible to miss.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.